foreign
[Music]
hey what's up guys how's it going
I thought I'd kick in a YouTube live
stream you know because why not it's
been a while twitch Partners don't have
to stay on Twitch anymore
so in preparation for London dare which
is going to be a live event we thought
that we would explore the possibility of
streaming on YouTube so what's up
YouTube
my name is jono as you probably know oh
man it feels weird streaming on YouTube
I used to stream on YouTube a long time
ago
um I actually want to see when that was
the last time I streamed on YouTube
[Music]
okay the last time I did a live stream
on YouTube was in 2014.
so and it was like Journal craft I think
I was working on ShadowCraft which is a
little Minecraft clone I made for like
University back in the day
dual stream on both uh I can't do both
like because I am still a twitch partner
and twitch doesn't allow you to do both
but also I don't know like I don't
really like the idea of
streaming on both platforms I think it's
weird
like why would you because why wouldn't
you watch on YouTube if the live stream
is on YouTube and why wouldn't you watch
on Twitch live streams on Twitch like
unless it's like banned in your country
or something weird like that because I
don't know in my opinion I think it's
better to keep the community together so
you kind of want to
you know keep it together
um so that you know everyone can
obviously chat in the same place and I
know there are like some weird websites
that combine stuff but uh like I said
they can combine chat I think from
multiple sources but that's really weird
because everyone knows what you know
what you're talking about
if they're only on that one platform so
anyway I just thought it'd be better to
do this
um I think I also uh did I not set that
up that should be working yeah the chat
I've got chat like um
chat's a bit weird because I used to use
streamlabs OBS when I streamed on Twitch
but then I kind of wanted to move away
from that and just go to like regular
OBS studio and uh there used to be a
plugin that I just use for chat you know
getting chat like on screen like what
you guys see here
um and then I kind of uh but but there's
no I don't think there's a plugin to get
that working on YouTube
so basically what I ended up doing
instead
is setting it up as like a browser
source and then using some custom CSS to
make it look different
so hopefully that works well
[Music]
um I think it should be okay
um yeah if you guys like while people
while I'm setting stuff up uh just
because I mainly want to make sure that
like you know the quality is good and
the chat is working and all of that
stuff uh feel free to ask questions and
I'll try my best to answer them while
I'm doing stuff but basically the plan
for today's stream is like I literally
just have work to do and I'm feeling a
little bit lazy so and I kept being I
kept getting distracted and just got
going on YouTube and watching random
recommended videos
never a good idea because that just
takes up so much time and and I think it
makes you even more lazier so what I
decided to do was I was just like oh you
know what let's just live stream because
then obviously I'm not gonna I'll have
to be focused because I'm gonna watch
when I get distracted with YouTube
videos in front of you guys I could but
I'm not at that stage yet or I don't
care so
um that's the plan uh we're gonna do
some work uh just because I'm working
hard on basically completing the
renderer rewrite for hazel because we
have like a bit of a different renderer
now that is a lot better when it like as
far as dealing with resources and
description
in Vulcan
um so that's almost done
it's really coming to to I hope to have
it finished in about a week or so within
the week
um
because we want to actually probably
like do another release of Hazel also
hazel20 2023.2 because we released Hazel
2023.1 like a month ago we want to do
another release actually at the end of
this month right in time for London dare
so that we can actually do that game Jam
so if you don't know a lot of desert
game Jam we're gonna do that game Jam at
the end of this month
um because it starts in like 24 days I
think or 23 days something uh we want to
use like the new kind of version of
Hazel that has like this new renderer
basically and some other improvements as
well so the plan is I'm going to kind of
work on that
Travis thank you so much for the 10
donation thank you for all the knowledge
and experience you provide to the
community my pleasure thanks for the
support appreciate it
are the music's a bit loud oh sorry guys
yeah I think this is what I mean this is
what I mean by setting it up yeah
usually the music is like at -15 DB in
my like mixer
apologize for it
[Music]
uh this should be better
um
[Music]
RFA is the most stupid photo
um
oh whoa wrong audio Source ah
sorry guys all right now we're good
so this is what I mean this is what
happens when you guys join the First
YouTube live stream in a while
and the reason why I did that is because
they're they're in opposite like say
this this is just like the I'm just like
muscle memory at this point because for
some reason the mic is below the desktop
audio in the mixer but I'm pretty sure
in streamlabs obvious it was above so
that's why
LOL okay anyway
um
is the chat almost looks a bit big
maybe I'll make the chat a bit smaller
because then it comes up too high I
think
let me just tweak that real quick
is the chat a good
um size
let me just see what that looks like
it's a bit annoying
um so
how do I yeah yeah
let me tweet this out as well just in
case
all right
um
yeah that should be
that should be it
yeah I wanted to just see yeah I think
that's not bad I think the chat's fine
might tweak it a bit more at some point
great
all right
there's some more space on the left side
of the screen for chat
based on the camera angle well it's like
most it's usually not
usually not uh the the normal view I
think would probably be
um a bit different usually because the
camera is just like usually it's not me
feeling the screen it's the screen
let me just get rid of this for a second
like as in this is like this is like the
normal layout basically so I like having
the chat like you know down there
um
all right
okay so let's yeah let's do some work I
guess
um
like yeah this is gonna be a pretty
chill live stream I did I did want to do
a live stream like an actual live stream
like a scheduled live stream and stuff
soon ish at some point
um
where we like I'll probably like
actually plan some content
um
but today it's just gonna be like
yeah as I mentioned it's just gonna be
we're gonna just do some work so
basically this is the state that we're
at I'll show you guys kind of where I'm
at I'm basically bringing back all these
render passes
um because they're now there's now a new
render pass system and a new kind of
compute Shader system as well uh inside
Hazel and so I have I've kind of been
slowly porting everything into that new
system and the reason why it's a little
bit of a challenge well not it's not a
challenge it just takes a while it's
because there's like so many different
passes to take care of
um but basically so this is prefab
sandbox which most of you familiar with
hazel know
um so I'm slowly bringing stuff back
there's still no icons so there should
be like these spotlights need to have
basically um let me actually set up my
things so I can draw on the screen
um like there's basically you there's
usually like little icons for all the
lights
um and other stuff like for the camera
as well I could see a camera icon that's
not there because that's disabled I did
like just before this live stream
basically I brought back
um text rendering because that flows
through renderer 2D so renderer 3D is
like mostly good I think there's some
missing features like for example screen
space Reflections are not in the new
render pass system yet
um
and what else is there
uh our animation nothing to do with
animation is in the new system so any
skeletal animation stuff just does not
work at the moment
um so I need to bring that across
obviously
um but yeah I'm gonna probably start
with like the rest of the 2D stuff
because that should be pretty easy to
bang out so basically as I mentioned the
like the icons which
um is actually what I was about to do
literally and then I was like ah why not
live stream this so here we are what do
I use to draw on the screen is called
Zoom it
thoughts on making a video on a book
guide for C plus plus
on a book guide video on a book guide
for supports I'm not sure what you mean
video what on a book about Staples Plus
wanted to say thanks for teaching me
most of the fundamentals of the plus no
worries Kevin
glad to help
all right
um
is the music too quiet now can you guys
hear the music all right
whatever doesn't matter I don't care
all right
so basically
um yeah so I was just about to bring
this stuff back so we this is where
we're under the tech so that's working
and I wanted to also maybe change the
API to make it a little bit easier but
basically this stuff I can just carry
across text index buffers line index
buff yeah this stuff I don't think has
changed much
yeah that just should now be a line pass
which I didn't make yet so let's go
ahead and make a line render pass
so we have a separate render password
lines because it uses a different Shader
and
um
and thus a different pipeline
and it's got some different Behavior as
well for like the vertex buffer and the
index buffer
uh okay so basically this and there's
also a line on top pipeline so we
probably need two different render
passes for that
so let's see what we have we have this
text pass for text so basically I think
these two guys
um
[Music]
so let's make this be the line pass
and then line on top pass so we'll
basically get rid of those pipelines
because they'll be inside the render
passes now
um and everything else I think is fine
so now we'll get these errors
and we can just make yeah so let's do uh
render power specification
and spec we'll say
it's a debug name
I think renderer 2D line
pipeline will be that
Pipeline
and then we'll make another one of these
foreign
I guess we can just do that is there
anything else in here that we need to
worry about marker color yeah I might
say that later
all right so
yeah so this will have depth test as
false and then we'll do
yeah basically that
okay
um and then this will be the line pass
um
this will be the line on top pass okay
okay so that they are our two things I
usually like to scope these in just so
that like these specs don't leak too far
so for example that makes it so that you
can't accidentally use the lines back
here by copying and pasting here because
you can see it's not something defined
in this scope
so
um that's generally why I like to make
the scopes for fun and it also helps you
kind of clean up the stack
you know if you need to
okay that probably is it as far as lines
go but we shouldn't have started with
lines we should have started with quads
because that's kind of
more or less what we want
so Line pass I think we can do get
to get a pipeline get Shader
didn't I add that I thought I added that
to pipelines I wanted to add a get
Shader because it's quite a common thing
to get the Shader
to want to get the Shader this sort of
thing that's funny
this was a thing back from like the open
jail days when Hazel used to support
both Falcon and opengl
um and primarily even from initially
when it only supported up in jail but
that's gone now
um
it's a wrap shade um
get Shader
and this function
Vulcan pipeline
let's do this like here I guess override
return mspecification dot Shader this is
a little shorthand so that you can do
that
um because you need to create this from
it oh yeah so you can see quad part well
quad pipeline doesn't really need to
exist anymore so yeah quad pipeline same
kind of story for quads
which I need to probably organize this a
bit more as well and do we have a quote
on top thing no okay so that kind of
becomes this now
quad pass
[Music]
um then we just look for the errors okay
so quad pipeline so that will now be
quad pass a round of pass create
Maybe
what is this music it's so like kind of
country and it's fine
whatever we'll leave it
[Music]
when was the renderer 1.0 ah
I guess that's what it's been up until
now
[Music]
the last year or so maybe
okay pipeline equals
this guy
[Music]
now that's not quite the end of it
though because he's telling to beg the
pass and everything
um so I'm gonna have to do more work in
a minute
[Music]
uh and then this is what is this oh this
was just for fun I think this is when I
was messing around and planning the API
itself
so this is yeah just quad pass get
Shader
[Music]
feel like farming some herbs yeah
yep the music is uh is definitely
[Music]
getting me that in that Vibe um all
right so
that's what that is and yeah so that's
kind of I guess we can bake it now so if
we look at the Shader and or the Shader
ones the Shader wants uh camera and set
one uh which means it has to be part of
the render pass I don't think there are
yeah and then this is in set zero
probably be explicit
um
ah that can be binding zero actually I
think it used to be one because this
used to be in set zero as well so now
that that's the handle so the material
has to provide the textures and the pipe
and the render pass has to provide the
camera which makes sense because that's
not per draw or anything so
um
let's go ahead and set that then so we
can do set input uh camera and we can
set it to like UBS camera which is
uniform of a set because it's one
uniform buffer per frame and flight
and uniform buffer sets and Hazel kind
of abstract the per frame and flight
part of that
um so let's see I wanted to look at the
other the text pass because that
obviously works
yeah so that just does that and then we
just do validate and big which is kind
of what I wanted wanted to steal
so validate and the little core verify
here we'll just make sure that bake
actually does a validate but if it
doesn't work
um we should probably you know what I
don't like I'm pretty sure that at the
moment the way I've set this up is it
just silently fails right
so if we go down to the end of valid
yeah like if it doesn't validate it just
doesn't do anything but I think I want
to
um
am I in the right scope here
the indentation should swear to HZ core
error tag renderer and we'll say uh
[Music]
and then we can do our specification
debug name
why is it so the invitation's a bit
weird
[Music]
all right
yeah so now let's go get a message but
in general that's why we do this and
this gets stripped in uh distribution
builds verifies are like asserts but
they stay around in um
release builds as well so it's like damn
um it's like uh
debug and release is
um debug debug it says the debug only
verifies a debug and release
and uh but in distribution builds
everything gets stripped so this line of
code will basically not exist at all
in distribution builds but in develop
release builds it will
um because you don't have to do this
that's one thing you want to be careful
of as well sometimes people put code
that
like has to still exist here and the
problem is like this obviously will
strip it entirely so if you had anything
important in here like don't put it in
here you could do like a ball
validate and then do a verify on the
validate like that so that this actually
Still Remains a thing in um
you know in every build
even I get caught with that trap
sometimes
too many curly Brack of braces I think
you guys mean that too much in too much
like nesting um yeah like there is quite
a bit here
um
yeah I guess I could have done like
obviously when I started it wasn't like
this you could I could have reversed
this and just done return right
and the rest of this assumes it's valid
I guess I'll do that now actually so
let's go back and basically be like
if it's if validate returns false
then we'll go back and print this
um
and return and then that means that we
can get rid of
that and pop that back a little bit
which is better I guess
[Music]
um
this is a lot of this is temporary as
well but the rest of it's kind of
necessary because we have like nested
for loops and switch statements and
stuff I could probably move it out into
functions but
I don't necessarily like to do that
sometimes what's what window you use for
navigation visual assist uh yeah I use
visual assist like well this is just
like control Tab and Ctrl shift tab in
Visual Studio but if you do alt m in
visual assist that's very very useful it
just lets you just drops down all the
functions and some symbols as well in
the file and then you can like
immediately start typing so if I wanted
to go to like render 2D flush I can just
do alt M and then type in flush hit
enter and you can see I'm at that
function
it only does nothing so I should
probably strip that
in general I'm doing a bit of a clean on
Hazel as well because like it's a bit
there's a lot of dead code in it a lot
of stuff that could be that needs to be
cleaned up and some a lot of code that
just doesn't do anything because it's
left over from a long time ago oh one
one more reason why I wanted to stream
on YouTube instead of twitch by the way
is because I can stream at a much higher
quality because twitch limits you to
like six megabits per second I think
that's just the maximum overall that you
can do even if you have like a 4K 60
stream or whatever it's still like six
megabits per second but YouTube can go
much higher than that I'm only streaming
at like 10 at the moment I think
um but I could because that's just what
it picked but I could go up
and my internet upload is 40 so I can't
go too high but
yeah it's still kind of nice obviously
to have it a bit more like that
um all right
[Music]
brother saying a q a stream
no I'm happy this is like this is the
first YouTube stream in a while so I'm
I'm not too
like I'm still setting stuff up and
whatever so even though I'm I'm giving
the illusion of me working I'm also uh
keeping track on this but yeah I don't
know why you're spamming
let me let me clean that up
let's just uh should I time out or just
ban on time down what's H Nu and H
delete for
um
uh allocation tracking
so basically it's a little macro that uh
if we uh if HZ track memory is defined
you can see it expands instead of just
being new which is what it is normally
it expands to this
um and what that will do is
basically whoops
what that will do is call
um
this function here which will go to
Hazel's allocator and it will basically
uh keep track of lots of stuff
and it lets us do some pretty cool stuff
which if you remind me I'll show you a
little window and Hazel that can break
down exactly where all the memory has
gone
um I just need to launch Hazel but it
doesn't compile at the moment because
I'm editing files so remind me
next time I launch Hazel guys remind me
to show the memory kind of
stats all right
[Music]
um
yeah so where were we uh yeah so that's
it we're baking that
nice and that's nice and baked now are
the lines as well we should bake the
lines get our lines baked
okay so basically that and that
and it's gonna need I think it just
needs cameras as well
line line can't spell line JSL all right
uh yes set zero and that doesn't have
textures obviously so it's just that it
doesn't even need a material are we do
we have a material for it because we
definitely don't need one we might but
we yeah we don't need one so this is
gonna need
um the camera as well
good M
um okay and now we can probably go on to
end scene and oh we need to set the
textures are they are they being set
correctly I don't know okay so this now
is replaced basically this was the old
card now it's replaced with uh this kind
of cluster of code so quad pipeline oh
sorry quad pass
um
quad pass I think we can can we do get
pipeline yeah we can
it's a bit better
um quad material which again that's the
thing that needs to have the textures
or vertex buffer quad index buffer quad
index count okay that's done
um so I just need to make sure that the
materials are set which they should be
so this is a a sample 2D array
or no I should say an array of sampler
2DS that gets set here
um based on the texture slots because
this is a batch renderer so that should
probably work
let's just hit a five and see what
happens
I'm gonna make a t-shirt called that it
says let's hit a five and see what
happens
oh everything's check out the lag
because it's using all of my cores to
compile
all right what are you guys saying I can
answer some stuff while I'm compiling
uh any alternative to visual assist as
it's not free
um not that I know of I mean Visual
Studio like with every new release is
basically implementing the visual says
features so it's actually not that bad
now but the old M thing is very useful I
don't think it can do anything like that
you could always write your own plugin
in visual studio if you want
um
Peter did that for hazel
so he would know
so the render is like a Singleton uh not
there are several renderers so it kind
of depends okay I'm not saying icons
which is unfortunate oh I might have
disabled them
um
uh the this renderer is kind of it's not
it's not really a Singleton oh no I
guess it is a Singleton because it's
virtual as well because this will
actually this will delegate to whatever
render API you're using so at the moment
we only support Vulcan but we used to
support both Vulcan and opengl and in
the future we will likely support we
might support like DirectX 12 for
example at the moment there's no real
need to do that because Falcon also
works on Windows and we're not targeting
like Xbox or whatever but this basically
would call this actually like the
implementation of render geometry the
real implementation is in a file called
vulcanrender.cvp and everything here so
like around the geometry as I said
everything here is is static right so
this stuff is kind of used statically
this does not retain any state
whatsoever so the context that it
records commands into is passed into the
actual function so the render command
buffer is where everything gets recorded
into and it's basically like a Vulcan
command buffer
um so this is like the static render
commands basically is what this class is
but the scene renderer which is the
thing that actually like organizes this
stuff
um and cause that that is not
um that is basically you can instantiate
that like per viewport for example
um because that can be used yeah
[Music]
so it's basically like the render apis
are static um but the uh because like it
it just translates to Vulcan commands at
the end of the day which obviously are
also kind of static
um but
the renderers themselves like render 2D
and scene renderer which are the two big
renders we have like renderer 2D renders
2D stuff in a 3D context though so for
example those icons they're in a 3D
world but they might like face the
camera at all time they're basically
Billboards right but they are still in a
3D world and they still respect like the
dev buffer and all of that so they can
go behind things
um the render 2D handles that as well as
all text uh
and that yeah that is not a static class
like this is not a static class you can
instantiate this as much as you want
um and same with the San Andreas 3D
scenes
the scene render is basically like Scene
goes in image comes out and you can do
that parallel in parallel on different
threads if you wanted to as well
um how much time does building Hazel
source code take poof maybe like like
two three minutes on my computer using
all the cores I have 32 cores or like 16
cores 32 threads probably
[Music]
wait do I have
let's see I don't remember I think I've
got 16 cores yeah 16 cores it's 59.50x
thank you thanks Joel Watson for the
dollar
appreciate the support
[Music]
how are you so fast am I getting your
code well yeah um I do use like visual
assist as we talked about earlier
but
[Music]
um
uh basically yeah just experience like
I've obviously been programming for like
you know a while
over a decade so like you you just you
become fast you know it's not something
that's happened it's like playing guitar
you can't like immediately play guitar
your fingers just don't know what to do
but eventually time goes on and you
become faster and faster Joel uh LOL I
gave you 99 Cents without a message
because I don't know how things work
paid so you can't ignore me uh just
wanted to know how you stay motivated on
Big Boy projects and thanks for being a
coda hacker Chad man
um how do I say motivated on Big Boy
projects
um
foreign
[Music]
like it it's definitely it definitely
can be difficult there are a few things
in head like there are a few things that
are different maybe about hazel that
will probably make me extra motivated
and that is first of all I work in a
team not by myself so if I didn't hire
like Tim and Peter and they didn't work
for me and I didn't have a team then I
think that would it would definitely be
harder
um so that's one piece of like why it's
motivational I like why I stay motivated
because you know it's really cool to see
like you know the cool art and stuff
that Tim has made for example in Hazel
and like the demo he's put together for
example and Peter you know just added
like a new physics engine or whatever
into Hazel like it's really cool to
obviously see the community around that
but not even them not even like Studio
Cherno which I like the staff but then
there's also like the rest of the Hazel
core team which just kind of are
volunteers right
so it's really motivating to see to kind
of work with people I think that's
really important especially for someone
like me because I'm quite a social
person so if I'm just doing stuff alone
uh it definitely does eventually kind of
burn out and become less motivated the
other the other big thing though is that
Hazel has come so far that it's so cool
to do stuff with it like in the
beginning when you make an engine like
probably for the first year or so
depending on how fast you are it's like
it's cool but like
um
it's cool but like you know at least
especially well I don't know maybe if
it's your first time doing that stuff
it's still super interesting and
motivating but like obviously I came
from like frostbite and before that a
mobile Legend called Osiris at EA as
well and like when you come from like
working on frostbite or like a bigger
engine and then you start making your
own stuff it's
like it's a very different thing and
it's kind of in a way it's fun and it's
it's nice because it's a lot simpler and
that that's easier to deal with
obviously but on the other hand it's so
incapable of doing anything that you
just feel like almost overwhelmed
because
you know what are you gonna do like I if
I want to make something I'm gonna have
to add so much code like it's so far
away from being able to for example make
a 3D game and ship it at that point when
you just start that it's like that sucks
you know that's really
um not motivating I guess but then as
time goes on if you push through that
you know like we ship games like well at
least twice a year because we do the
game Jam we do let them dare twice a
year now as a team so together as a team
we make games in Hazel every six months
and we ship them like and it's cool
because you know even the progress
between that is huge like Forest the
first game that we made like a year ago
for a lot of dare
you know that basically shipped with all
of the raw assets and it was single
threaded and then if you compare that to
dichotomy you know this isn't even like
editor improvements this is actual like
engine fundamental engine runtime
improvements like by the time I got to
dichotomy six months later like we had
asked everything was packaged like into
an asset pack so no raw assets and it
was a multi-threaded like run time right
so like
that obvious and you work in a team to
like make a game that people can then
play and of course it's not perfect like
of course like there are performance
improvements to make there's like GPU
compatibility improvements to make like
it might crash sometimes like I mean all
games Crash but still you know it feels
different when it's your own engine it
feels like it feels like it's it's
almost like sometimes I like to use
sometimes I like to use other engines or
I tell people to use other engines
because like I feel like when you when
you get so involved in writing your own
software you forget that literally like
every other piece of software you use
pretty much like will crash
right like I think it was funny because
when Tim was editing a year ago when Tim
was editing the video
for forest for the London dare game that
we made
I think Premiere he was counting how
many times Premiere Pro would crash and
thank God we're well past Premiere Pro
like I've been using DaVinci for like
the last six months at least and it's so
much better but anyway
um he would count how many times
Premiere Pro would crash and I think it
was like something like 50 plus
basically the point is Premiere Pro
crashed more times while making that
video
because it was like well to be fair it
was pretty heavy because it was like it
was like basically all of our live
streams
um it was taking clips from all of them
and it was like 72 hours of footage I
guess per person pretty much well not
quite 72 hours but you get the point
like a lot of footage it was like over a
terabyte I think of videos but he had
proxies for them and everything but
anyway
um the point is it was still like it
crashed more times than Hazel did during
the development of the thing
and like obviously Unity crashes on rail
crashes like everything crashes and
sometimes like when you just work on
your attack you forget you almost have
this unreal unreasonable expectation of
like oh damn it Hazel crashed you know
this wouldn't have happened if I was
using Unity or unreal and to an extent
like I'm sure that you can have more
bugs maybe than maybe an engine that is
way more complicated but on the other
hand has like proper QA and everything
but still like it's
um
you just need to remember that like
software crashes and like it's okay you
know unless it's like you know the
autopilot on a plane then it's not okay
but for video games and for
entertainment it's fine for crashes
[Music]
anyway that's the motivation speech so
Joel Joel Watson I hope you got your
money's worth
um what do I think about sea lion I used
it a little bit like four years ago I
didn't really like it the thing is like
you know people say this every now and
then but like the fact is visual
[Music]
Visual Studio is basically the it is the
tool to use for like video game
development like that everyone uses it
in the industry like I mean I'm sure
there are some people especially now
with like engines like Unity that are
using like Rider or whatever by Jeff
brains that's fine but like for
fundamental engine development and for C
plus plus like no I don't like everyone
in the industry is a visual studio like
and again it may have it may be slowly
changing but like it's not only just
because it's capable of dealing with
large projects really well compared to
other tools right like every time I used
to fire up our code in xcode because I
had to build an iOS build like that
wasn't just a nightmare like with the
same code base like Visual Studio is so
much faster but not only that it's
because a lot of like manufacturers like
Sony for example they make debugging
tools for like the PlayStation as
plugins for visual studio and at least
back then they didn't make them for
anything else
um so it was kind of like you basically
had to use Visual Studio
um so
yeah and like I don't know for for the
people who rave on about like how oh it
sucks so much like it's so slow it
crashes or whatever well like I don't
know I mean to be fair like I don't
remember the last time it crashed it's
actually been really stable lately which
is good I remember you scratched more
often
um and it used to be a bit slow and it
free it's froze and stuff like that now
it's actually really good for me it's
been really good in Hazel and Hazel's
not that big but it's not that small
either
um
and also like yeah I I don't know I just
feel like the people who complain a lot
about like Visual Studio being bad and
like they make it their passion to just
complain about it all the time are
people who are focusing way too much on
the tools and they should actually focus
on the work they're producing because I
think that's a lot more important than
like what text editor fundamentally
you're using
um and that can get really annoying as
well when people are just too obsessed
with that what music is playing it's so
nice
um the music is called
um Pearl City Beach by paper twins oh
that's another good feature of YouTube
live streaming you guys can like just
rewind can't you like you can just go
back yeah you can go back and watch the
live stream from wherever you want to
um
and uh and if you miss something or you
want to see something you can just go
back a little bit or as you can't on
Twitch so yeah I don't know I'm really
enjoying this YouTube experience at the
moment to be honest Vector thank you for
the donation or mate any resources you
recommend for Vulcan
uh
it's difficult because
um
I I don't know I guess like I I would
say if I had to name one resource I'd
probably say Sasha Willems examples so
Sasha Williams has like a bunch of
examples on uh GitHub
um
yeah
well basically I'll just show you guys
on my screen but basically this guy
right
this guy
um he's got like his Vulcan thing he's
got a bunch of stuff but um if you look
at this this is like you know examples
on literally everything if you already
like if you kind of already understand
how
like rendering I guess works on a high
level and you just need to learn the API
this is the best thing to do and and you
know especially I feel like as a
programmer just reading through the
examples learning from the actual code
is so so useful and he you know he gets
into other like interesting things like
Shadow mapping he has one on on Bloom
for example which I kind of dissed in my
Bloom video because it's a it's a bad
example of Bloom
um but it's a good example of how to use
the Balkan API to achieve something like
that
um you know there's even Ray tracing
stuff I think I think yeah he has like
actual Hardware accelerator Ray tracing
examples as well which are good or
decent keep in mind none of this stuff
is like AAA grade or like industry grade
but it's really really good for just
being like how do I do this in Vulcan
um or how do I do a technique like this
you know that might for example render
to a depth buffer and then I want to
sample that depth buffer in an in the
next render fast how do I do something
like that in valken this is the best for
that kind of stuff so that's my number
one resource that I would recommend
I wonder if you can get chat gbt to uh
tissue Falcon I did I haven't like I
haven't used chat EBT too much for like
hazel but I did like I have been playing
around with share GPT a little bit like
I asked her to like write me some um
just some simple house code for fun
which actually I think I'm gonna make a
video about it because it's actually
quite kind of cool and really
interesting like you can get it to like
write you like for example a data
structure and then you can ask it to
tweak certain parts of that data
structure to be more customized to what
you want and it can do that so that's
really cool
um and it looks like the code looks
pretty fine and you can ask it to like
annotate the codes with comments that
explain everything like it's it's pretty
cool but no I haven't used it like in
work specifically
yeah it's pretty good pretty dope
[Music]
um
unreal energy out of this feels super
unreliable compared to shift executables
a lot of the time for some reason
yeah I mean editors are a bit of a
different game when does a lot of their
start in like 23 days I think like end
of April basically you can go to
ldjam.com and look at the countdown
foreign
what was it like to make your first game
using Hazel must be a proud moment yeah
it was cool um it was like it's the
thing is like the first thing we ever
actually made was probably the Space
Invaders clone and that took like months
so like probably half a year and like I
it drove a lot of features definitely
and it was like more of like a technical
thing than like a game you know but it
is a game but like it was
um it was a lot of it was a good
technical exercise basically so that
didn't really feel like you know
straight away but the first item that we
did with hazel which was Forest which
was like a year ago
um yeah that was really cool uh it the
game was somewhat broken on release and
we had to patch it because
um I think uh one of us who I won't name
wrote The Movement
um in a you know using using Nvidia
physics but
using it incorrectly basically and so we
kept getting stuck in the mesh collider
um which was a very bad and gambreaking
but I fixed that that same day even
though I had been up for like
was I up for 24 hours what was that for
24 hours during dichotomy
I don't remember
anyway
I was very tired to be like oh he's made
a game in Hazel and it was broken so I
was a bit upset
um but once it was fixed and it wasn't
like a great game or anything but it was
definitely cool to release that I think
dichotomy was a lot cooler just because
we shipped it without the raw assets and
it felt more like a actual distributed
game and it had like multi-threading and
everything
um
all right anyway
[Music]
interesting Why YouTube stream and not
twitch if you guys go if you you can
actually again another feature of
YouTube you can rewind obviously and go
to the beginning of the stream and watch
me explain why huh I don't have to
explain myself twice that's pretty cool
um
all right I'm gonna switch back to some
work
so
yep I do play guitar I play guitar and
piano
there's a piano here but you can't see
it
I'll prove it
there we go
proof twitch is just as everywhere yeah
I've YouTube I I definitely like I think
I like YouTube more
YouTube's just up there live streaming a
lot I think lately
we just made it really cool
um Okay so
let's say
um
where do we stop
surely play something for us cutie um
well uh maybe not now but I did
yeah I I we did it a lot a year ago for
the London day where we made Forest we
did it like as a charity stream to raise
money for Ukraine
um and one of the like I think the two
thousand dollar
Milestone reward was basically a little
concert for me so
um but I don't think that's anywhere on
the internet like there's a Snippets of
it here and there but yeah so I did do
that so maybe we'll do another charity
stream for something
uh this let them dare
which yeah guys by the way so in 23 days
we'll be doing a three-day stream a
three a 72 hour live stream basically
um where we make a game
using Hazel so stick around for that
it's in like 23 days
here it is which by the way let them
down the home page has been completely
destroyed but anyway
um
I can't anyway here it is yeah 23 days
20 hours
um oh the spam is gone oh there's a spat
they installed the spam bot finally
after like this home page was just
completely destroyed with Spam for like
so long now it's good
that was weird the stream just dropped
out I think for a second
well at least OBS just dropped out and
reconnected that was weird
I'm still alive yeah guys
be funny if it was because I opened
Hazel
um oh yeah I was going to show the
memory view so if you go like I think
maybe views and statistics so we have
the statistics panel there's this thing
called memory and so what you can do is
in memory
um it basically says total allocated
total Freight and current usage so this
is not like the whole application but
it's like most of the application
um and this stuff you can kind of ignore
that's just the total this is the
current actual usage so these will both
keep going up as you kind of have
transient allocations
um and then here you have this little
sorted list of what actual classes
allocate memory
um and if that if they're not a class
like you know for example this is just a
file as you can see it tells you the
file so sometimes you get classes like
actually these are all files I think
everything that's blue is a file and
then this these are all actual classes
right so you can see that like you know
scene renderer has 300 kilobytes of
allocated memory buffer.h has 50
megabytes of arcade memory now
unfortunately that doesn't tell us much
because buffer.h is like a little
convenience class for allocating raw
buffers or not necessarily allocating
raw buffers also like passing around and
managing raw buffers
um in like a non-owning way uh and then
yeah we can see like render command Q
This is a static allocation I think like
this will just allocate once at the
start of the app that's why it's exactly
50 meg but yeah this stuff is used and
it's cool because you can obviously
search for like you know if you wanted
to validate something if you've written
some code and you want to make sure you
don't have any leaks you can just kind
of monitor this like a hawk and be like
is it out any of these increasing
um and then you'll obviously see uh
you know if something's increasing frame
to frame because you can see this stuff
well this stuff is
um like as in these two up here are
but then this guy shouldn't really be
increasing like it's possible there are
some I'm sure there are some leaks
somewhere in Hazel are not claiming it's
leak proof but it looks pretty decent as
you can see
which is good A lot of them dare uh well
ludum dare is a it's a game gem
basically there's like two versions of
it component jam and there's actually a
new thing called extra but you basically
have like either 48 hours to make a game
by yourself
or 72 hours to make a game in a team
um all right anyway so that's the memory
view that's the can I not close this I
guess not there's no close button I
should probably add that
uh okay so yeah I think I didn't enable
the icons being rendered so if we go to
uh honor in 2D
um
I don't know this should be rendering
because that's
should not
yeah that should be rendering hmm
that's weird
uh
yeah Round Rock begins in set Target
forever why are we doing shouldn't we do
probably not a big deal but I feel like
we should almost do these the other way
around I don't think it's a big deal
though yeah why are we not why is
nothing rendering so where are the icons
so show icons has to be on which I'm
guessing it is and then it just does
like draw quad billboard which goes into
the quad so as long as like in an end
scene
as long as we're actually doing that
which I hope we were so this is it right
so
this looks like it's rendering
that's weird that should be rendering
rounded off time no not quite not yet
why 72 hours as a group don't you need
more time if you're solo um I don't know
that's just the rules so I don't make
the rules
we've been joking about we've been
joking about making Cherno Dare for a
while
um
which is funny
but
uh and then I would make the rules but
that's not the case at the moment
um all right so I mean sure icons is
definitely on so that's a bit weird
let's just Chuck a breakpoint in here so
it is trying to render it
um could it be rendering it to the wrong
buffer possibly I mean this is also done
as a post-process pass this text this is
done
using your Android 2D and it is going
externally so we should just make sure
that we're doing the same thing
um so if we look at this it's setting it
to renderer get external composite frame
buffer is that what we're doing here
yes it is okay and edit a camera of your
projection give me metrics yeah that's
basically what we're doing here
I mean here we are doing it this way but
that doesn't seem to
matter so yeah why is it not
um
yeah and if it's got a final pass image
so the text is rendering fine funnily
enough
so maybe we did mess something up oh I
think I know what it is I think it's the
set Target frame buffer it doesn't yeah
so what has to happen which is somewhat
unfortunate
well
does it have to happen
I don't know
maybe
yeah I know it's pronounced dare but I
like saying dare because
that's just what I do
um
yeah so we basically have to kind of
recreate the pipeline basically uh and
the reason why we have to do that is
because the
frame buffer like well the image
internally changes I don't really know
if
if that's strictly speaking necessary
because I don't think the frame buffer
changes I think the attachment image
reallocates
but I think that's just the API the way
the API is set up to be honest so let's
bring this back I'll have to bring back
circles as well
um but yeah basically this has to do
this so we can grab the I guess we
should just copy this I think
um
but when where is it gonna recreate it
oh we don't even have to regret the
render pass apparently we just
recreate the pipeline
huh and that should work
and here we're just randomly checking to
see if that's equal
um
it could be any of them though because
they're gonna we're gonna change all of
them
so that's a bit interesting uh
uh yeah I guess that should work and
then we can do that for lines as well
I don't know if I like this system but
that's what it does at the moment
let's see
three o'clock I should make myself a
coffee
all right well that got our icons back
but they are not textured why
I don't have any welcome validation
errors
um okay
yeah
why do they not have that same thing
happen with fonts by the way
so I feel like because initially they
also were not textured
um so I don't know why
I think someone asked a question earlier
why this starts from one and not zero uh
it's because zero is reserved for just
the default kind of white texture
that's why because if we don't have a
texture and we're trying to render a
quad then what happens is the color of
the actual quad gets multiplied with the
texture and so we just set a one by one
pixel white texture
um into the texture slot basically and
then we multiply the color with that if
it's um
if there's no texture otherwise
obviously if there is a color set that's
not white which is the default and there
is a texture it will tint the texture
um okay so that's yeah circles we need
to bring back as well I don't even know
what we'll use circles for like I can't
think of anything because I don't think
we have like a circle render a component
or anything
but whatever
um all right
so what was I doing
um
yeah the textures so the texture slot so
we're just a quick material set but with
the text material would be oh no no
that's right
yeah that should probably work
as long as we render with the quad
material so why does this not work
because this works and I think it's
basically the same thing
hmm that is suspicious isn't it
that's suspicious
[Music]
yeah I didn't miss anything else no well
we're definitely rendering into it it's
just we don't have a texture
[Music]
how wouldn't we have a texture
I really can't think of why
um let's we can also look at the uh
the glsl Maybe
but this is pretty standard so it says
there are binding zero so sends it yep
and it's uniform you font atlases right
so this is called you textures yeah and
it's basically the same thing
so
some excellent music
called Penthouse saucy
um
what am I looking for
yeah you textures
this is bizarre
because it's literally the same thing
I mean West yeah we're clearly trying to
set that I'm in release so this might
not be the most debuggable thing to do
yeah we're not getting anything here
oh but this looks like a white texture
what
so why is this setting a wash texture
huh
look that's not
oh zero
okay that just happens to be your watch
or
but Point light spotlight on camera
these look like valid textures
yeah these are the these are basically
the textures that we're using
and they should be being set like into
the correct index
this is the same thing this the text
renderer does so I assumed it worked
it maybe it's a bit different because
it's not index zero though
maybe maybe there's a bug
should be binding the right one
oh that's big
what does prepare to
yeah that looks like
looks like it should be the right one
if input size is greater than one
otherwise these input is zero yeah this
is a bit wrong maybe that's one
yeah that could be why I think it's
because of this
oh it's gonna be annoying
and it's probably gonna slow things down
a little bit but basically
um I think this should be a vector
so it will basically be zero everywhere
I think this is I hope I'm right
[Music]
if this works I'm gonna get my coffee
um okay so yeah for that it's fine
for this it has to be
yeah I don't really like this because
this just checks the first one
it should probably check all of them
yeah okay
so here it needs to check all of them
basically so we can I think we can do
because it distracts the first one for
some reason so this should actually go
through
um because I only made this work for
textures at the moment but
um like all right because that's all we
have we don't have arrays of like
storage buffers for example which we
probably will in the future
maybe for like Ray tracing or something
that might be useful
um but uh
[Music]
input dot input dot size nine plus plus
okay
so this is now I this is now I
and then if we do that we break and that
means we break from this as well okay so
that that's that uh now these need to be
um
properly set up though so when we find
the descript account we need to also do
input dot input Dot
uh sorry input dot uh
where do we store those resource handles
[Music]
are in the right descriptor
oh
but not that one all right we said it's
an all pointer okay so
um
yeah basically that should be easy to
change that just means that when we do
this let's do this let's do
[Music]
well no we could do this we could do
that basically
[Music]
so we've resized it to the right amount
um
[Music]
and now
yeah and then we set it to the right
amount and then here yeah so this is
fine this is just going to be zero
everywhere I think
[Music]
yeah that should be okay
um but then the difference is here
instead of zero uh it won't be zero
because it will be
[Music]
well in this case it'll be zero and in
this case it will be set
by the for Loop to to be basically
this
I think
I hope that works
okay
Yeah so basically what was happening I
think this is my theory
um is that uh it was like what render
passes do is
um basically
any inputs that you send that you set
onto a render pass in Hazel in the new
system
it will um basically like
uh
like before beginning that render pass
it will basically check to make sure
that you've actually got valid
descriptors for every resource you're
planning on using
um and the problem is for arrays of
textures where you might have you know a
lot of them we were basically only
checking the first one and seeing is the
first index set correctly so does the
descriptor that vulcan's going to use on
the GPU to actually use that texture is
that actually valid to the you know the
image view of the texture that's set you
know kind of on the material or on the
render pass doesn't matter because they
both use this system
um but obviously we need to check all of
them because if any of them have been
changed like if you've changed this to
like some other material or sorry some
other texture then you obviously need to
like re you need to update that
descriptor set basically so I think
that's the problem
the program I used to draw on the screen
is called
um Zoom it
how delayed the stream is because I just
have it on normal latency but I know I
can set it to like something better
yes I can go make my coffee now all
right so you can see we get icons
so
that's a good tick
and a BRB
all right I'll be back in a sec
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what I miss
okay
I missed everything oh no
Myra Waters coffee yeah exactly so I can
keep working
all right so
do I use mstf or Mt stf2 around the text
oh
one of those two
I don't even remember I think it's just
normally mstf
all right so we've got icons back that's
very exciting I'll just play work
ah yes
seems to work all right good
um all right oh and actually I think
we try loading sponsor
that should still work yeah because
sponsor uses textures that other scene
prefab sandbox literally doesn't have a
single texture anywhere so it's
important to test on this as well
because
this uses textures
this looks like um the color space looks
incorrect as well
I think this is um linear not sr2 beam
which is wrong
um but anyway
and this should work as well right
all right
um okay so that seems to work
uh we what is left oh um I guess let's
do screen special reflections because
they're not in the new system yet
um screen space Reflections which by the
way you can enable in dichotomy so I
wanna before I
dichotomy is like my kind of test in a
way because this new kind of system
should massively improve the render
thread performance of dichotomy oh well
off any hazel game
uh but dichotomy like has like you can
if you play dichotomy enough and you
shatter enough players because you can
break the player apart into pieces and
then they don't disappear those pieces
like well they disappear when you clear
the level but not before that and so um
that was a lot of CPU load so that
should be a lot better now
that's pretty much like my benchmark
um
so what was I gonna do
um yeah so as I was explaining uh so
because that's a bit of a benchmark one
of the things that we need to do
um well one of the graphics features of
dichotomy supports is screen special
Reflections so we need to bring that
back so I'm going to bring this back and
we're going to Port this to the new
system and I don't know how that's gonna
like I'm not sure what we'll encounter
along the way because I'm pretty sure
this this is quite a few passes
including some compute passes as well
but hopefully it'll be okay
so basically we'll make a render pass
now I'll keep the pipeline for now
actually I can probably get rid of the
pipeline as I introduce the pass so this
basically becomes a pass instead
yeah so you can see there's like three
different compute Pipelines
that I used which they basically become
compute passes now
uh
I was trying to decide what to call
compute passes because they're not quite
a pass but I just figured that
language-wise like compute pass makes
more sense compute passed around a pass
that kind of just plays nicely
it's possible to rebuild the economy of
the new system yeah absolutely this is
just back-end changes so yeah I do plan
on making a new release of dichotomy
like when this is done hopefully that
will improve performance for you know
people if they want to test out that
game
um all right so
lots of Errors probably now but let's
take a look at this so
I'll just copy
like something else as usual let's copy
I want to copy
that doesn't really matter let's just
copy this
thank you
so there's the pipeline doesn't have a
render pass anymore it doesn't have a
what was that it doesn't have a render
pass anymore but Target frame buffer has
basically moved on to the pipeline now
um render par yeah this I think this
just all goes away
right
um and then we can create SSR composite
pass
okay and now we actually have to look at
what Shader that uses and maybe adjust
the Shader so it uses the SSR composite
Shader so if we look at that Shader oh
that's very simple
um this is just this is honestly I don't
even know this probably doesn't even
need to be a pass I didn't write this
this could probably just use one of the
full kind of bledding things
um but yeah it basically just reads the
texture and writes it into the out color
but whatever we'll keep it
because it probably has like a special
blend mode and everything
um but yeah so it basically it's just a
uniform sampler here so that's it so it
actually doesn't need any resources in
the pipeline we could get rid of the
yeah we probably should get rid of the
material entirely if we move this to set
one any any set from one to three but
not zero then it will basically be per
pass rather than per draw
um and so that means what we've
effectively done is moved it to be now
the render passes responsibility to
control this resource rather than the
material
so that basically eliminates the need to
even have a material so we can just get
rid of this material
as long as we obviously specify this
USSR texture as an input here so we can
look at the material because we used to
have it right
SSR material and if we look at
um
that's got to be a different one we have
to start composite material
yeah so you can see it was set to mssr
image so we can go back and just set
that to be mssi image as long as that
went as where does that get created
that's probably getting resized maybe or
not
no this is getting created
um I don't know why it's created this
way
why make
why do that
um but basically this where does that
get created oh at the very bottom that's
funny um let's not do that
you can still kind of do that maybe but
the SSI image will create
well anywhere really above this we could
do it here
um and yeah we'll just set it as an
input basically into the SSI composer
pass and that's it and we don't need a
material for that basically
um now what does this do so frame offer
existing image geometry pipeline used to
be the just zero on the app so this is
that now just geometry pass
uh get output zero
um okay so there's the composite pass
now let's have a look at how that used
to work
I wish it used to be I guess composite
pipeline or whatever
oh yeah and we have to make sure that
that gets resized as well because it's a
screen thing I don't I I will def I
think I'm going to clean this up and
package everything in like there will be
a data structure that holds all these
bosses because at the moment at the
moment even though they are linked
together kind of like a graph because
they deal with outputs and inputs and
stuff like that they're not exactly
links in the way they should be and
it would be better to actually make a
graph out of them
but it basically is kind of functioning
like our underground
um so
but there's some lots of ideas as well
that I want to implement
so if we look at uh
um this I'd like to do M SSR
Target frame buffer which I'm just going
to resize now
I don't think it actually has its own
frame bumper
I'm pretty sure that where we wrote it
is
it uses an existing image so it's
actually not going to resize it here
it's going to uh just obtain the new
image as an attachment that's all
so this isn't quite going to be a resize
but that handles that
um I don't know why this says dependent
on Geometry
okay but that was just the that was just
the easy part that was the SSR
compositing
thing
pipeline so this was the SSR composite
plus let's just fix up the pass now so
obviously this we don't need this
anymore
I'll leave that comment the current made
um begin render pass is just
that
uh the pipeline is going to be here and
that doesn't even exist anymore I think
instead we just need the material which
is null so
[Music]
maybe I should make that a default
parameter probably
uh that's it
um that's the entire compositing pass so
yeah no more material which is nice
it's not it's not a huge difference in
this case because it's still one draw
but the benefit is obviously if you have
uh shared resources like for example the
camera camera doesn't need to exist in
every material like it kind of used to
um because it's kind of just set it's
that descriptor set is bound at the
beginning of the render pass across all
the static meshes and all Dynamic mesh
and surrender
for example for the um you know geometry
pass okay uh yeah so let's move on to
just the SSR Pipeline and stuff
um
why is that just used here so let's uh
maybe I might just search for SSR
and see
[Music]
yeah so SSR composite we obviously did
and then there's just this and that's it
that's a bit suspicious but sure because
what about all the r but there are other
passes I think that just aren't called
SSR that are using SSR
anyway let's move that here for now
because all this does is it creates a
pipeline and a material and that
pipeline I guess is used in SSR compute
so let's make SSR compute work so this
is obviously dispatch computer this is
obviously a maybe I'll keep that
um this is obviously a compute this is
going to be a compute pass so if we go
to SSR pipeline that's a compute
uh yeah so I've kind of made into a
compute pass I think but
um
yeah okay
so what we need to do is basically
SSR pass equals compute pass
create
compute
pass
specification
debug name
I'll just call it SSR computer
pipeline is going to be
compute
pipeline
uh do we even have a pipe I guess we can
just do this I think we don't need a
spec just a Shader
yeah it just takes in a Shader that's
cool
I guess
um so we got that what else was there
just the marker color okay that's fine
um that's for like showing up in render
Docker inside it can you can set a
marker color so you can color your
passes
it's a debug thing
um
okay beautiful so we've got the that
path set up now we probably don't need a
material for it but we'll see
SSR compute okay
um yeah so you can see all the stuff it
sets which again it used to kind of do
here
um which wasn't the best I think all of
this can be done up front which is
fantastic so if we just copy that
uh and we're gonna go up here which by
the way in case it wasn't obvious this
section up here is basically
this is like the Constructor kind of
it's the init function so this only
happens once when you create the
renderer when you create this instance
of the scene renderer
um
um okay so this is the SSR pass which we
need to eventually
do this too
um and then this basically what I want
to do is I want to make this be the SSR
pass set input
uh we're gonna move it up so that we do
it here
and
um this is this is the uh first image
right index one from the geometry passes
will just be geometry pass get output
one
and this metal on this roughness is
geometry pass get output two
so we have those color attachments being
fed in
um
and then all this yeah so basically out
color and all this stuff that's inside
this SSR Shader needs to be now in Set
uh one so it was originally in set zero
but now we're moving it to set one
it's probably it because it's part of
the past now not the material and yeah
again the material can just go away
which is nice
uh we're not using this yet okay
um SSR compute yeah so that's great
that's gone
uh oh we also need to do this we're not
using um I I don't know if I should
bring back HBO because I haven't done
that yet just gtao I don't know if we
necessarily still need both maybe I
should just scrap HBO
but this this new gtao tax which
here
this might not be used
um
Yeah mgta final image
uh okay
so back in SSR compute
so this stuff's done
um I guess
now we just need to do basically this
should be easy so we can grab that in
do that
it's our option
foreign
just a style thing
um dispatch computer okay so this
basically needs to sort of dispatch
compute is what this is now called it's
a different thing SSR pass
none of this stuff
material is also null but I don't think
yeah material goes here no that's there
and that's there
and then before that we need to do begin
compute pass and we pass in the SSR pass
and we also need to do end
compute pass all right so that's that
should be the same functionality as
basically all of this
it's just now the resources are set in
the pass and they are bound to the
pipeline here
uh okay
so now
now
uh
so there were all the other passes that
needed to be done as part of that which
I don't think are yet so we'll have a
look at them in a minute
but
yeah so yes it's like compute well
so yeah like pre-convolution compute I
think is needed and pre-integration as
well
so you can see this is four Sr
and this is unfortunately a Karim wrote
this to be very custom which I'm I think
he had a reason for doing it that way I
think he did it's because it uses
individual maps and hassles API can
handle that
um but it will in the future
so I need to make this work
um which is a bit annoying so what is
this this is the
so this will take a bit of time
um
this is the
where's the pipeline or where's the
pipeline pipeline pipeline pipeline
pipeline pipeline
pipeline
all right sure well let's start with
that
um
so
yeah this is it so this will become
a pass and already it kind of is a pass
all these things have kind of let me
just make them all passes now
so that I don't forget
um
because that would force us as you can
see to make the changes
oh
come on
it's conflicting with that
again material probably not going to be
needed but
yeah
I think I'll end up doing this this way
foreign
[Music]
because I'm fairly sure that we'll want
to
pass it in here instead of into the
material which means we can probably do
something along the lines of like gosh
and blow pass set input and then you
know the texture basically to that guy
so what's this it's called
pre-convolution
so what does that take so we have an
output image and an input image
let's see what sets the output image I
think that might yeah see in this case
it's actually done manually so we'll
leave it for now like this and
the reason why it's done manually is
because
um probably because uh
we specifically need to get an image
view in Vulcan bound to a specific MIP
and we can't do that using Halo's API so
I need to add that into Hazel's API and
then what I do
which it is planned just not probably
before under
um or at least not now uh
we have we're going to keep doing it
mainly and then we'll eventually switch
off the switch over to the new system
all right so where was I up here
um I wasn't up here
it should have been
so much
to say okay
um yeah so we'll leave that maybe as is
so we'll still make the material and we
won't set any inputs we won't have any
inputs because if you're the trader
they're all in set zero
why need a specific map
um because it it's going to Output I'm
not like Karim wrote the SSR thing but
for example in the the way the bloom
works is that because it needs to do
like lots of down sampling passes and
lots of up sampling passes we basically
create a single image with a map chain
and then every pass we basically sample
from the last MIP and we down sample
into a smaller map but that's part of
the same
um image
so
uh that's why we have to make sure that
for that for example we have descriptors
that actually create a Vulcan image view
for each specific MIP
um and I'm guessing this maybe does the
same thing because it's a gaussian blur
I didn't write it again as I said but
I'm not going to change it yet
um
I will change it later uh when we
actually because what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to create like an image
view in Hazel as well that we can just
use because Hazel's API does support
getting image reviews for each map
um like you can see we use RT get image
view for example here to get like a
specific map an image of a specific map
but it's just that it doesn't quite
handle that as a resource and thus we
need to create the descriptors manually
which is not good
but we will do we'll fix that up later
all right
um
okay so then let's go to so we've got
pre-integration and
I guess that's different okay well let's
just do this one then um
so this will just do pass get pipeline I
think
not much to change here really
and unfortunately this still does the
old system like it uses the old system
where it will basically allocate
descriptor sets every frame
um which is not what the new system does
anymore
um but it's okay because
it should be okay
but yeah
how many other people have worked on
Hazel with you um well like Studio
channel is like there's three of us
um
but then the community like we've got a
bunch of volunteers as well uh so in
total
I'd probably say about eight people or
nine people maybe
um
have probably contributed like
a sizable amount
okay
um yeah so that should be okay I don't
even think we have to change much here
luckily at least not yet
so this we can probably just enable
um and there are going to be some things
that change like this no longer oh we
need to manually bind the descriptor as
well at the moment
okay I'll make that happen yeah
okay okay I better do that here actually
so if we look at like Bloom compute
where was that one line two seven
um we used to do it yeah basically this
line here
So This Is Us finding descriptor set
and the command buffer
command buffer also needs to be a thing
where does the command buffer come from
it should just be here
oh um I guess we just have to do
get active command buffer Maybe
that becomes
buffer
yeah then we're doing the bind
descriptor sets uh okay so that's good
and then I think we had to also do that
yeah here
and then it does it twice
does it have to bind to the descriptors
at both times
no it's the same descriptor set okay so
we can actually do that here
a little bit better than doing it twice
um all right
pass get pipeline
uh uh this is what Target frame before
look at how long this this used to be
crazy now let's just get output
was that the first one yes so zero
now input color image uh yeah so as
Vulcan
image 2D
um all right yeah so there was also that
uh
where was it this the interleaving pass
I think is also necessary
or maybe not maybe that's used for HBO
that might be used for HBO
what is this used for yeah HBO compute
okay cool I don't think that's used by
SSR
uh so is that really it
at night if this will work so
pre-integration we bring back
pre-convolution computer we bring back
NSS in
okay
um
yeah
I'm gonna control F7 that
time is it in Cherno land almost four
o'clock
yeah like 10 to fall
let's try around that
foreign
text not found and that's apparently not
all right
uh ugta attacks not found
really
there oh is this not used
it has to be used
oh or maybe that's actually set off
um
I don't even know where that would be
can we do a search
it's the default set too
none okay well that would explain it
so that's fine I guess but the other
problem is that this is
Jeremy thank you for the two dollars
nice guitar
yeah it's not bad
it's probably my least favorite guitar
it's the office guitar
it's pretty good though it's fine
um
yeah so what's the other so this is null
right so Russell's null you highs that
buffer so we probably just haven't
created it yet at the time of setting it
so that's fine
um
so where are we first of all doing that
what's a call SSR computer or something
no no SSR pass
so where is it it's
is it this one high Z buffer right
so where do we create that
yes it's created lower
um so let's
maybe take that and just make sure that
it's
above here I'll just stick it here why
not
what is my computer setup
I should make a setup video
um
the heck was that
uh computer setup
um well yeah so where do I begin
well the computer itself is like uh
5950x AMD CPU like 32 gigs of RAM 3080
uh in like a nice white case
and the uh 3080 is white as well which
is nice
um and then I got two monitors here like
LG 27 inch quad HDS
resources null input color
okay
input color
is pre-convoluted texture which I guess
is also done later
that's should be okay yeah sure we just
move these up a bit
because they need to buy the other thing
um I got I actually got some decent
audio monitors as well like Yamaha hs7s
I think
yep actually checked that
uh
screen dot is now we must have how about
we just move this to like the bottom why
is it here I think it's just too high
let's take the SSR and just move it to
like be the last thing we make how about
that
now everything will be made
can I download Hazel uh you have to
become a patron we do want to do a
binary release eventually but if you
want all the source code and you want to
build and stuff why is that null
it's green data shouldn't be now
um uh yeah you can go to patreon.com and
it will help support the project
and you can get access to Hazel as well
objective thank you for the five dollar
donation for your hours of work creating
educational content and making difficult
Concepts easy to understand she is
considered viewing leaked game sources
um thanks I appreciate the
appreciate the appreciation
um all right so what's the problem here
yeah what is the problem
races are not screen data
I never set screen data
what shouldn't that just tell me that
it's not oh oh this is validation
failing so that's actually correct yeah
um so screen data so we need to set the
screen data so that's easy we just find
another pipeline that or another
password does that like this
and then we go back and we add that in
camera okay
hey it launched all right do you guys
think it'll work though
let's enable it
nice nice little crash oh that's just
null
that is just straight up now how's that
possible
Vulcan Material
ah it's oh it doesn't have a material so
that's easy that's just
that's just something I haven't uh I
forgot to do for this particular
function
how many people currently work on a
Hazel uh
no it's not just me it's um so Studio
channel is three so there's three of us
so there's two more people on payroll
apart from me uh and then well I'm I
have my own payroll
um and then there's uh a community
there's a bunch of contributors in the
community as well a bunch of volunteers
there's like
maybe like four active ones
so um yeah quite quite a quite a decent
team
all right um as is all right so let's
try and enable SSR you guys might not be
able to see it because of the face cam
but uh I guess I can move it here I'll
move it here
I can get rid of that
um let's move it here
so here it is enable us uh
not another crash
um all right so oh okay we just don't
have an image there I'm trying to read
it so that should have told us that it
was null
that we ignore it
yeah because that means I'm in release
as well oh I'm in release let's try
build it in debug
so the image was not available a
the image is null hmm
have I tried god.4 no uh well I've used
I've tried Godot before a little bit but
um haven't tried four I hear that it's
pretty good
[Music]
foreign
come on
[Music]
I have to cancel it and redo it
well I consider making Hazel and open
source engine
um well there is the Hazel 2D which is
open source
um probably I don't have any plans to
make the big Hazel open source and the
reason is that
um the fact that it's not open source
and you have to like pay ten dollars on
patreon to get access to it is the
reason why it exists
because that's like how we fund it
um
oh I was running this without
Falcon validation error as well that's
not good oh that's fine actually this is
uh is it it's a bit annoying but it's
kind of fine
um all right yeah so for that reason
like I yeah I have to think like I don't
know
if maybe like if we release some games
with it and they're like super
successful and that covers the funding
then we can maybe make it open source
but
um you know it doesn't cost that much
money to get access to it and that's
obviously how we can develop it so
yeah and you can use it for whatever you
want basically once you have access to
it those are like royalties or any other
licensing complexities
um okay what's your problem
okay
right so it's not compatible with
these descriptors or whatever somehow
really what pipeline is this
it's the printegration pass pipeline
[Music]
foreign
let's have a look at the Shader
so what is this this is the
pre-integration
um so does that use anything from
anything else
yeah it uses projection param so that's
why I think it's oh that's a push
constant sorry
doesn't use anything else it doesn't
look like it does I mean the the thing
is if it the render pass
the render pass uh
validation would have picked it up
though that's why this is weird
[Music]
so what is it it's saying that it's
that pipeline is not compatible for
maximum set satica use zero
with boundar script it says last bound
with that pipeline layout
which is the same one Falcon spec States
for each set and that is statically used
by the pipeline
bound to the pipeline bind points used
by this Commander descriptor set must be
bound to n at the same pipeline bound
point oh
no
what what point are we oh are we just
not binding it oh sorry I forgot that
this was
um yeah yeah that makes sense I forgot
that this was um custom and not going
through the render pass so basically we
just forgot to do
um
we just forgot to do
uh this kind of manual uh bind
descriptor sets
so we have to do basically
if we can do it here
command buffer and get active command
buffer
by plug compute and descriptor set
so basically that yeah it was just not
bound at all I thought it was maybe a
different set that wasn't bound because
I was confused why it wouldn't be bound
but it's because it was manual and
yeah that's another reason why that's
bad
what model formats is Hazel support
um well usually gltf and fbx but
you can theoretically use anything
because
um
we like is asympt for importing and then
the runtime will will sort it out into
its own format uh okay so shall we
enable SSR
yep and it was Simon we get a validation
error so
um that failed with error right update
that blah blah blah attempted to write
update in description view use being
used does not have a storage bit set
what
okay
so we created this without a storage
like this not as a storage image
I mean I guess it might be true
because I'm pretty sure you need to
Define storage
huh
don't know how that worked before but
storage should be defined as true I
think is the reason for that not working
yeah if there's asking about Vulcan and
how to get started with Vulcan I someone
asked that earlier in this stream and I
recommended Sasha Williams examples
um because they're really good if you
well at least if you understand
rendering in general
is this stream going to be archived on
YouTube yeah I'll leave it up I think
cam
okay so I think was this what did we get
this before as well I think this is why
we initially switched so somehow this is
null
um and what is it exactly
it's an image 2D
binding seven and set one
ah
oh that's the GTA 01 isn't it
binding seven yeah it's this one so yeah
that one actually doesn't exist though
but that I think is fine isn't it
because we don't really want to use it
but I guess we've said it have we said
it
yeah I guess we said it and it's I guess
it's not all right that's why it's upset
I think so maybe you shouldn't have said
it
um
this is it
but why is it null
GTR final image shouldn't be now
it gets created like in a different
place
oh I need to make sure we resize all
these passes as well
but
ah oh I get set here
that's why it is null okay
because it's one of these two basically
depending how many passes we have Okay
um
yeah okay let's just set it to like this
one
for now
you're not really supposed to update
like we could make it a material if it's
something that can can get updated like
that otherwise like you can I guess you
can update it
technically you're allowed to update it
like let's actually try that I'm curious
so if we're going to begin saying
let's actually try and do that
like because that should update it if
it's changed and if it hasn't I don't
believe it will
because it's gonna do a set
oh no it will just it will yeah it will
set it
but if it will only change it if it
differs from it will only actually do a
VK update descriptor sets if it changes
from
if it changes from um
what it already is set to on the GPU
hello how do you compile shaders and do
reflection
um
well we use uh spurvy to compile the
shaders and do the reflection and then
we basically package it into a custom
kind of binary format that contains the
uh optimized Shader bytecode and also
all of the debug kind of reflection data
and we use that
um
so that we can basically still retain
names of all of the uh
you know all the resources we're using
the shaders and we can still kind of use
them around the engine even though we're
running the optimized version of the
Shader
and then you can create something called
a Shader pack as well which is necessary
for runtime but optional for the editor
so yeah it's mostly just like superv
reflect I guess
um is the actual library but then
there's a lot of there's quite a lot of
system on it you can always go to
patreon.com get access to Hazel by the
way guys it's really easy to do that now
did I tell you there's a little this is
a little ad I guess
for what you're seeing here but um
we made it like really really easy to uh
get access to Hazel now so all you have
to do is go to patreon.com sign up for
the supporter 3 tier which is ten
dollars a month
and then once you've done that you
literally just go to get.hazalengine.com
and you just connect your patreon
account and your GitHub account and that
automatically instantly gives you access
to Hazel so for those of you who like
were around
you know a long time ago you know that
you had to like manually message me and
then wait like possibly up to a week to
get access depending on because I only
only went through the messages once a
week and they were usually like 30 or
40.
um
but now it's all kind of automatic so
feel free to test that out
and thank you for the support
um all right let's try and enable SSR
ah when is this gonna work
um all right so oh I guess there is no
uniform storage profile why is it assume
that there is
oh because oh sorry because there's no
material that's my bad as well
[Music]
did you guys enjoy my ad
do you ever catch yourself when we're
making the code you learn during a time
at EA or do you try and keep the code AS
original as possible or do all game
engines or for its own techniques
um I guess I've like picked stuff up
here and there but there's like the
reason why I would probably ultimately
say no is because I kind of have my own
code style like that is stronger than
anything I've learned at EA meaning like
when I write code
it's kind of like you know the way that
you express yourself in a way is like
you know when you're writing code you're
expressing yourself through that code in
a way and like because the stuff at EA I
guess didn't influence me enough to
change my own style it meant that if I
sit down and write code I still have my
own opinions and my own ideas that are
stronger you know in terms of like being
a determining Factor on how the code
turns out
compared to
um
what I would have learned or seen at EA
you know
so uh I guess that's why but also the
other really critical thing is that like
in a way I can't mimic that code if I
was to try and mimic the code that is
used in frostbite in a way like it it's
a very different ball game you know it's
kind of like again I always compare this
for some reason to like building a an
A380 for some reason so if you're
building an Airbus A380 that's just my
go-to
um kind of metaphor analogy thing
um you know it's kind of like let's just
say you're building a little plane in
your backyard like just a lightweight
like Cessna style plane right but then
at work you go and you work on a on an
on an A380 and of course you're just
doing a really small part of it like the
airlock
right so
you can't really integrate the airlock
from the A380 onto the Cessna maybe like
you probably can but like let's be real
like that's just a waste of time and
it's definitely not going to be
necessary and it's also like you know
it's the two completely different things
even though they're both kind of game
engines they're both planes
it's still very very different so
whatever you know it's just it's you
just don't have the resources to kind of
do the same thing
um
and and if you and if you like I also
have to like look at Hazel and be like
look yeah I know that like maybe I could
you know make something like render core
for Hazel and render core is something
frostbite uses for all of its rendering
basically it's called render core
um I think Unreal Engine has something
that's named exactly the same thing but
basically like yeah I could do that I
could make some kind of render command
encoder and like just some crazy system
you know that would be useful and
you know that'd be fine but on the other
on the other hand it's like what's the
point like what is the end what is the
goal here the goal here is to ship games
do they need a system like render core
no
would they benefit from that possibly
but would they benefit enough to justify
the cost and the time
take into write a system like that no
because the end user that plays your
game is not going to be like oh yeah
this doesn't feel like it it has a
proper rendering system like it doesn't
make sense right like yes it might
marginally improve performance might
marginally improve compatibility and
whatever but again the keyword is
marginally
um so when you're working on something
you know again to go back to the A380
analogy it's like if you're working on
the A380 then maybe every dot every like
because it's at such a large large scale
every like every liter of fuel or
whatever counts like so much you know
and if you can tweak something in like
the airframe to make it have slightly
less drag and therefore Suddenly It's
like over a trip you know across the
Atlantic or whatever
it's gonna suddenly you know or the
Pacific it's gonna suddenly have it's
gonna have like like I don't know
thousands of dollars or hundreds of
thousand dollars of fuel it's gonna make
that difference and that's worth doing
but if you're you know flying planes in
your backyard and around your local area
you prop that like that kind of
reduction in drag that same one percent
reduction in drag or whatever it's
probably not going to be
um
necessary you know so that's basically
like another way to look at you know
what it's like writing code maybe for EA
versus an on frostbite versus like just
doing this stuff
because like the thing that people don't
understand as well is that like you
don't need massive amount of features
and very complicated technology to make
games
like you just physically do not need
that
like you know I really I love looking
like one of my favorite examples of
recent times is Minecraft because
Minecraft is obviously a huge Global
success like it's sold more than lots of
AAA games I'm pretty sure it's is it
still like number one when I sold game
of all time or something like that right
like it's crazy and like look at the
tech did that use an engine no because
it didn't need to like the game is not
like nanite Lumen Unreal Engine 5
graphics that's what you need and
therefore you should use Unreal Engine 5
because you're not gonna be able to
replicate that Tech yourself which I
agree with you're not going to be
probably not going to be able to
replicate it to that degree yourself
right but on the other hand it's like
well do you need that Tech
maybe if you're making a photo realistic
game that's supposed to look like it's
fully path traced maybe but if you're
not
you know if you're making a kind of
abstract and like you know a game like
Minecraft because at the end of the day
games are just art anyway so what they
look like is uh depends like on what you
want them to look like right
um then you don't need that and you can
just build you know you can even build
no engine you know you don't have to use
something like hazel which would
massively make lots of things easier you
know
um because it handles lots of stuff for
you you could just actually start from
scratch
so yeah
Tetris is number one yeah but I guess
I'm more talking about modern games
Tetris is old
uh okay let's try and enable SSR again
okay well I can press the checkbox
and it doesn't crash so I guess now All
That Remains is for us to maybe make the
floor
um have a
smooth material
so let's make it reflective
and is that yeah so that has a reference
of zero so that definitely is not
reflective so I don't think the SSR is
working unfortunately
microphone's too loud okay sorry I made
my microphone a bit quieter
that still seems kind of loud maybe this
is better yep
it's just annoying because like the last
it's like at 99 but the last one percent
is like lots of gain
um all right so that doesn't work
unfortunately
so yeah we might have to
uh
that looks weird
we might have to uh crack open around
dark I'm probably just not doing certain
bosses or whatever
escape the floor reflective I'll save
the scene
um because we should be we should be
wait are we compositing the SSR properly
we're probably just not compositing it
maybe
um let's go into
scene around
so the composites
SSR composite pass this is definitely
happening right
I think we should be doing that yeah if
the enable usara should be doing that
and where is that compositing into
uh well it's using its SSI composite
pass which should be using
um
the geometry pass output
as long as that happens before actual
compositing I think that should work
and it does
so why
why is that not working
are we missing anything
okay I'm just gonna I guess I'll just
run this through around the dock
SSR screen space reflections
that's not the right
path
foreign
directory
this is located run time
does renderdoc have a dark mode by the
way do you guys know
seems like an oversight
[Music]
settings oh yes it does
nice have never used rendered up with a
dark mode before
thank you
okay let's just do a little screenshot
okay uh
[Music]
it might not be
jtir
[Music]
why is this a song
okay here's pre-integration so
definitely doing something here
what's that doing
well it's uh I don't know doing
something
um yeah I do want to know where the
actual
so this is the same composite already
Bloom up sample yeah so before Bloom AR
composite where where does that happen
okay IO composite happens before this
and then we do pre-convolution compute
which we are definitely doing
um and then we just jump flooding and
then we do SSR compute after that
it's weird it kind of looks like it's
not running
like it just yeah it goes straight from
jump floating onto bloom
so it's literally not running why
yeah it just looks like it's already
where's the um where's this though
that was definitely right right
debug build yes
hmm
[Music]
pre-convolution compute should be
running though so yeah unless this is
off
so it almost looks like enable SSR is
not on but it well it has to be on
because I turned it on
but that is what it looks like
um
so jump fly yeah so pre-convolution
between AO composite and jump flood pass
or whatever and it's not here
unless this is it
which it's wait that's light coloring no
it's not
just goes there for some reason
[Music]
Ah that's a different thing
that's enter underpass I don't know what
this is
huh
okay well that is definitely surprising
oh did I turn it on before the caption
no I didn't oh my gosh that's so dumb
sorry I just kind of zoned out and did
the wrong thing
yeah because it's not on by default and
I I turned it on when I ran Hazel last
time but now it's just not on
ugh that's silly
how are you guys enjoying this live
stream by the way
is this something that I should do more
of I mean I kind of do this every now
and then on Twitch but it's kind of fun
on YouTube
and I guess it automatically stays up
right
okay so let's turn SSR on this time and
now let's
take a screenshot take a capture
all right there you go so I can pause it
um
yeah so it does nothing I guess because
the input is just not
it doesn't look good
ah yeah you know what I think it might
be but I'm not surprised it's not like a
validation error I think what it might
be is um these passes they don't like
they all need to kind of be resized and
they don't really need to necessarily be
resized
they just need to be like whatever
images that they use
that are kind of linked to something
else so such as this Frame buffer which
is part of what as it's like composite
Parts by doing that one they like
pre-integration potentially
but that has its own visibility texture
which I guess
yeah it does get resized
um
what other things are kind of important
here and that's compute really so
so maybe that already is handled
and that is all for HD
uh for hbao
not off we need to do
SSR composite pass
oh yeah I should be I forgot to stream
it
uh I was gonna change that sorry I
thought I was streaming at 1440p but no
I forgot to change it to that next
stream will be 1440p
hopefully the quality is still fine
though
okay so that looks fine
let's go back to the beginning which I
guess is this
so output image is this I don't
understand why that's
not there though
so
pre-convolution
so it's this texture that actually has
to get ah if to do nice so that's the
problem it's just a one by one texture
okay that is what I was looking for so
now I think let's try that again
just have some code disabled I'm
surprised that worked I guess because it
did exist it was just not a real size it
was one by one
all right glad you guys are enjoying
this stream
because like I don't know the
alternative would have been like it's
not that like it's not like I work it's
not like I spend most of my days
programming like this it's just some
days I like this especially coming up to
like let them dare where I have to
actually write a bunch of code instead
of just like making videos
um and so that's why like when that
happens like kind of like today the
alternative would have been just me not
like doing this without streaming it
because I would have still been doing
exactly the same thing maybe I would
have got more done although maybe I
would have got less done because I would
have kept getting distracted
um so now do you guys reckon this will
just work
yep so now we have as you can see
beautiful screen space reflections which
of course disappear when you go off the
screen
but pretty cool
[Music]
yeah screen space Reflections are
special
it's a debug build it's a bit slow
all right cool so we've got SSR back
which is nice
I think that was half resolution
can we make it yeah so we can change it
from half resolution to full resolution
which might be hard to see
but if you pay attention
uh well that actually kind of makes a
big difference on the edges for some
reason but yeah
that's half resolution that's a full
resolution
makes it a bit better
um but yeah that does seem to look good
we make the floor
oh but we don't know what material the
floor is
how about we just make this reflective
[Music]
I wonder what screen space Reflections
will be like with this thing then
[Music]
this is a light so
it's kind of hard to see I guess you can
see it
like that's check that out you can see
how that's reflecting the ground
so that's not bad not bad
what if we make this a cube
[Music]
Cube
hey look at that
nicely reflective
why is that so bright
it's a lot of light
from somewhere
[Music]
yeah it's pretty cool
it's kind of like a mirror oh and you
can probably
uh play with the roughness to make it be
a bit rougher the reflection which I
think if current tracing is on which it
is
should look a bit better
it's hard to tell though like that
doesn't look that great
metallic
I have it soft shot
it's reflecting so much light what is
that light is that really the skylight
maybe the Skylight is just very yeah
it's quite bright
[Music]
it's not quite blurring it the way I'd
like
wasn't always like that thing is I don't
remember
may have always been like that
but like it just seems to kind of fade
the color I guess that does kind of blur
it out
I swear you still look better
[Music]
there's lots of parameters to play with
inner brightness
but yeah
all right
um
yeah cool so what have we done today we
got 2D 2D rendering back we got a screen
space Reflections back
lots of stuff is back actually
um I'll probably almost try and play
dichotomy
we could probably try you know what we
could do we could probably try and get
dichotomy in
[Music]
I don't know if it would work because
um
we might like we might need extra code
but I could try and open the dichotomy
project in this version of Hazel because
it's actually the dichotomy branch
that I'm on still so it maybe it will
work
um
Let's uh open project
oh no that's
oh
that's weird that's like a memory
corruption error
ouch
let's try another thing
yeah that I should probably invest again
um
let's try and open
[Music]
dichotomy like that
okay well that is weirdly broken
and that's suspicious
this is weird
where the texture's at
not look like dichotomy
yeah this is oh and it just like the GPU
just crashed okay that's very suspicious
I wonder why that's that happened
I mean it is it is a potentially wrong
version of Hazel but
it shouldn't be that bad
uh well okay let's try a debug build for
one
I forgot that was a release build
ah we should do
[Music]
this
do I use tools like Val grind yeah every
now and then it's a bit difficult though
yeah a bit difficult because it's not on
Windows what was the rest of that
message
foreign
[Music]
so what's your problem
um
ah
yeah so this might use different render
calls or render commands which might
mean that certain things are a bit
different
[Music]
and then if it's rigged then that's game
over as well it is rigged okay so I
think this is the animation not working
coming in because we need to make we
need to get the animated pipelines
working
um that's possibly why because you can
see it's supposed to do all of this
stuff which this is not good this is not
great
um
but wait what was this doing tab
descriptor sets let me animation data
descriptor set and that was bound here
we could maybe just try and enable that
but I don't really like that idea
foreign
but also the storage buffers yeah
because they're not supposed to be per
drawer anymore
so that's why that's disabled
um and I do have to go soon
unfortunately I don't know if it's worth
tackling this now
um but basically
um
if we look at the geometry part the
sorry geometry pass that we create here
um yeah so there's a pipeline for
animation and then I don't know if we
created yeah I don't think we did create
a render pass
for animated stuff so we need to
Geometry pass
animated
pipe pipeline anime apparently
probably called Adam pipeline or
shouldn't be here at all actually but
whatever
um so
geometry anim pass
no
haven't made that yet
okay and then what inputs do we need I
think we basically need everything
um but there's also more things there's
this guy so set to binding four bone
transforms that might conflict with
stuff
if we go to buffers do we include
buffers yeah we do so that actually
shouldn't be here
that should be in buffers
not the hlsl one the glsl one
yeah okay it doesn't so that should be
here just so we can easily see the
bindings make sure they don't conflict
successful but yeah so we need that one
and that's burn transforms what's called
so we can just also set basically
do it here for now SBS burn storage
buffer set burn transforms
uh and then yeah this obviously
had to be done
for here
we need this explanations
all right so
oh yeah and I have this weird thing at
the moment I think that I'm doing where
I'm setting these guys up
[Music]
somewhere yeah here
which doesn't really
no it's not bad actually I think that's
fine
[Music]
in all seriousness
um all right so there's the Adam pass
and that now has the right storage
buffer
so really now I think that does that
really just work that would be pretty
amazing
oh but we also need to make sure
pre-depth is done animated right
so
hurry here because I do have to go soon
um so where's the animated one
pre-death pipeline Adam uh pre-depth and
impulse we actually already have that
with that in there that's amazing all
right great
so do we are we're actually doing it
though I don't think we are so begin
render pass here
um yeah and we basically need to do
so this is different
um we the thing is we kind of have to do
this again on somewhat unfortunately but
it's actually better this way
um pre-depth and impasse
so no static meshes here and just
through the draw list anything that's
rigged
basically
so it just changes kind of into that so
we only do not read here and we do
rigged here
uh and that's it I think
and pre-depth anim passes the key
all right
um and then in the geometry pass
we now need to basically do Dynamic yeah
so that's actually all done the same and
then inside Vulcan renderer we don't
need any of that
so it should kind of be the same effect
oh I don't know hang on Geometry parts
so if it's yeah so here we need to do
the thing that we did again which is um
uh why was this done twice
oh transparent stuff well that's not
that's we didn't actually I don't really
support that at the moment
um
so let's duplicate this
[Music]
and then I'm gonna basically take this I
think
there's all these performance markers
which will ignore
geometry and impasse
no sag meshes obviously
so they're not animated and then here we
only do the rigged
and that's probably just an index here
I'll get rid of
these timestamp queries
and this I think has to go here
um all right tell us the animated stuff
geometry Pipeline and I'm sure
yeah and then here we just do the
opposite
all right
um I'm interested to see what will
happen here
hey Peter's here what's up Peter oh can
I make you a mod
add as managing moderator or standard
moderator
I don't know what the difference is you
can be standard for now
try that out
powerful Peter
uh all right that just flat out did not
work
Max Bones on declared identifier
um all right
I think it needs both of them
yeah now Peter has a little wrench
next is named to signify the engineer
that he is
[Music]
great definition
in aware
in yfr because wireframe anime has that
um
yeah
so now it's in a in an include
and directional ah the the Shadows
so what's happening with shadows at the
moment
um
[Music]
is it just not doing oh it's still doing
this garbage okay uh
did we make an animated version of this
yeah we did
[Music]
luckily I set these up earlier it's kind
of nice that I did that
[Music]
hot Shadow map and I'm
all these animated shaders
[Music]
oh pretty depth Adam I thought it looked
at that already ah
I did not
have I tried rust and uh not not
seriously no I haven't done anything
major in Rust
I don't really have a huge opinion on it
to be honest it's just that like you
know
I just feel like
um it's like I don't I just haven't had
a need to really look at any other
languages like I'm happy with table plus
and C sharp which we use for scripting
stream delay well you can customize the
stream delay on YouTube so I can make it
much quicker I've just got on normal
latency but there's low latency and
ultra low latency which from memory is
pretty good
oh we launched
but will this work no
directional Shadow map's upset
ah because it needs extra
things
um
I expected this commands of a Vertex
spawning index to be set but I guess
it's not
um all right why is that the case
oh because I got rid of this maybe yeah
so we still have to do this somewhat
it's just that we have to do this I
don't think we have to do this because
that's all the descriptor set
so this just needs to be done and it
wasn't
you guys talking about Java
it's funny
work
whoa
that is unfortunate
yeah I don't know what the problem there
is
that seems like something's invalid
ah well also we haven't found this
is actually in a different thing but I'm
guessing it's rigged
it is rigged of course it's rigged
that's why it's not working
um
because it's rigged
so
yeah I mean we can bring this back
that I don't think was done anymore so
this can also all go away
that can go away fist goes away
to bind the vert the extra vertex buffer
though but I'm yeah I don't know why
that was the case
maybe something wasn't set properly in
the material
hmm
make sure we do this as well
and that should surely
be checking for the material
why does this not even
isn't this render mesh with material so
where's the material
what
yeah that's not great
and this doesn't do it either what
if it has descriptors we're not even
binding those
so that's what this is what it should be
doing
um
let's find a place to copy and paste
that from
yeah this is basically what it should
look like
for every thing
or at least this
but that also that actually should be
there
and where's layout here
so basically this block here I probably
should make that into a function
and push no push constant shouldn't be
there maybe
or should it
be out
so we do that separately from this but
the uniform storage buff I don't know
why it's written like this should be
done there
I guess layouts you can
do out here
oh
I hope that was correct
probably is huh
or is it
no that I think that's supposed to be
first
yeah because I said an offset of 16. so
actually
it should be this
glad I checked
yeah I don't like this
and why does that happen to be here
all right anyway I'm gonna have to wrap
it up because I gotta run
but I hope you guys enjoyed
this live stream
I'll try and do more of this this was
fun
let's gonna see what happens here
[Music]
well that's not correct
why does that not give a
oh there's nothing here what
oh this seems weird actually this scene
where's the dichotomy saying gone so I'm
in here
all right yeah we gotta clean that up
all right thank you guys for watching
hope you enjoyed the First YouTube live
stream in a while
um the VOD should stay up automatically
but
yeah
have a good rest of your day and
everything and I will
see you next time
goodbye
foreign
[Music]